[موسيقى]
علم الروبوتاتي تطور ليتجاوز كل معارفنا
عن الروبوتات التي كانت تستخدم في
القطاعات الصناعيه والتصنيع وتدريجيا خرجت
الروبوتات عن هذا الاطار لتدخل في عالمنا
الحقيقيه وهذا تسبب في تحديات كبيره على
الروبوتات وابحاثها وفي نفس الوقت توفر
امكانيات المدهشه لتقديم الروبوتات
لمساعده البشري في منازلهم
[موسيقى]
مثلا اذا ما اردنا المشاركه في عمليات
خاصه بهزه ارضيه او اذا تعذر ارسال البشري
بشكل امن داخل مبنى فسنستطيع ان نرسل
الروبوتات
[موسيقى]
هناك تطبيقات عديده فقد بدانا مؤخرا بباذل
جهود كبيره في الروبوتات تحت المياه التي
سمحت باستكشاف عوالم نعرف عنها اقل مما
نعرفه عن القمر او حتى المريخ والمحيطات
كما تعرفون تمثل نحو 70 في المئه من
كوكبنا ولا يمكن ان نغتصدون المئه متر تحت
مياهها كل ذلك جلب تكنولوجيا جديده
لمساعده البيئه والعالم وكذلك البشر
[موسيقى]